you're in this showbiz world you worked
with all these amazing people and yet
you don't seem that bothered bias like
when you were nominated for an Oscar did
you go yes but I reckon I was the only
person in the limousine going to the
Oscars with sandwiches and so I said
I've got to have sandwiches I couldn't
make the bread but I thought okay said
there was myself and Jim and daughter
and and I actually had animate with me
and I ordered these sandwiches and we
had them I said right let's get the
sandwiches out analysis taking agent so
we're here we weren't hungry and I had a
bag full of snacks so yeah I went there
and just you know I thought oh god how
English of me just to go and what about
the my daughter was you know she was 11
at the time so I can't have her hungry I
can't have her sitting there starving
one of those once it's somebody else's
name called out you've then kind of
rewrite history and you kind of thought
oh well of course I was never going to
be in it was always going to be there
look a bit of you has to think
somebody's got to win it yeah it might
be me yeah well I sort of knew that it
would I don't literally know when it was
you know you've you've got an Oscar I'm
not bitter
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know my film was quite a contentious
filming I've played an abortionist so
that was a difficult subject for a lot
of people funnily enough so and Hilary
Swank got the Oscar that year for
million dollar baby which was brilliant
and then I did a film with her later
that year so you know I couldn't I could
look at her myself saying it's for all
of us it's about the work there's a real
unspoken anger though that you're not
talking I would tell you two quick
stories if I may please
thank you very much who was the first
one that said I think Jack Nicholson
said to me he said QB cuz I didn't movie
with a lot of actors that I like grew up
like idolizing and then sharing the
screen with them you like whatever they
say you hang on every word he's in QB
when you nominated you're hot until that
award show when you win you're hot for
one year and that's it that's it in
Hollywood cuz the next year you're
replaced by the next winner and then
they get that kind of calling card yeah
but here's what happened with my
standing ovation now I listen I'm not
taking away from you no brother lost his
[ __ ] out there we know that room like
this room of audience here and everybody
here is nominated so everybody has to
picture go ahead baby everybody here
thinks they could win so potentially we
have a roomful of winners yeah I walk
out I lose my mind
everybody's like that's me by the end of
the show you know a room full of losers
the best film is everything in that
first half hour to show that third hour
people are hungry
[Applause]
[Music]
you